[Música]
ah
un antídoto es una cura y neutraliza y
contrarresta un agente tóxico los
sentidos de los que le hablaré hoy
comienzan hace pocos años
y mira para mí fue darle un nombre a una
actividad que he hecho toda mi vida
diseñar pero el valor del diseño está
como ejercen su impacto
y para mí ese diseño es muy importante
porque es esa búsqueda de
ese detalle de cómo vamos a crear este
impacto de cómo un usuario reacciona por
primera vez por sorpresa con el
resultado de una idea
esta idea comienza en el 2007 cuando
junto con un grupo que fundaron hoy en
adelante jóvenes contribuir nuevos
proyectos que estaban realizando ellos
en la mosquitia e intencionalmente el
guía turístico nos llevó a uno de tantos
parches que existen como estos que son
deforestación es ilegales que existen
esta jungla tropical que es como nuestro
segundo amazonas
la mosquita como muchos rincones de
nuestro país
posee una arquitectura que es vernácula
que es espontánea que trabaja con esos
materiales que tienen in situ
donde está expuesta a este clima
selvático tropical que tenemos
este es nuestro planeta
está dividido y repartido por tres
partes de agua esta agua toca las costas
en un 10% de momento no tenemos un
planeta número 2 no hasta que y lomos
nos lleve a marte
esta es nuestra honduras
conectando las américas
está llena de estos senderos milenarios
de aldeas que eventualmente se fueron
convirtiendo en ciudades las ciudades
que hoy conocemos inicialmente ese
sendero
era correspondido por sus seres humanos
de una manera sostenible
y había mucha conciencia en ese
recorrido en ese entorno claro mucho ha
cambiado
a pesar de todo es un territorio
sumamente bondadoso tiene 700 kilómetros
de costa en la parte del norte y 153 en
el sur
costas que para muchos de nosotros
guardan nuestros mejores momentos
caminar descalzo en la arena
tomar de hecho de que cada vez que
visitemos estas playas siempre van a
estar ahí tal y como las recordamos
lamentablemente hace ya de 90 años se
creó material que con mucha ironía
comienza como material ecológico
porque viene a reemplazar el uso masivo
de la madera y el acero en la
construcción muebles utensilios
y escenas como ésta se repiten mucho en
honduras cómo masca útil la
tela
y lamentable mucho mucho mucho de este
plástico ni siquiera es maestro tiene
por mareas
hoy en día existen 5 iluminaciones del
tamaño de continentes de este material
que va flotando y rodando porque es un
material
espectacular tiene una oración admirable
y en lo que va rodando y triturando se
se convierte en micro partículas
pequeñas
que son coloridas y llamativas y tan
bonitas que se confunde por alimento y
los peces se las comen y después que
suceda
cogemos los peces
entonces quizás ese menú que nosotros
esperamos cuando vamos a la playa o el
que nosotros adquirimos en el
supermercado puede llegar a cambiar
y probablemente sea algo te enfría
hoy dejan introducirles a su nuevo
condimento
y yo partículas plásticas enriquecidas
marinas
[Música]
esta imagen para mí corresponde a una
analogía de cuan positivo es el ser
humano quizás ese hombre que está ahí
sentado en ese barco piensa estoy bien
va a pasar nada estoy en una distancia
prudente y así somos todos tenemos
tiempo mañana término si hombre los
términos dos días mañana limpio
pero pronto nos vamos a dar cuenta
de que no es así de que no tenemos
tiempo
yo también he sido cómplice de estas
libras de plástico que se generan porque
son dos libras de plástico a la semana
el ser humano general de sus casas
en botes de detergente de champú bolsa
plástica botellas de agua y algunos de
estos tapones también son de esos
recipientes que yo utilizaba que fueron
conveniente y preferiblemente diseñados
para mi consumo
tapones que luego yo me encontraba en
esas playas que tanto quiero
pero también llevamos un tiempo de hacer
bien las cosas en honduras y así como en
el útil a time centro en una tarde en
una actividad que hoy llaman beach clean
up
lograron recoger más de 600 libras de
este residuo plástico como flota es muy
fácil recopilar lo
hay algo muy importante que yo quiero
explicarle soy la diferencia entre
recycling y app cycling s offside clean
es utilizar esa materia prima que
nosotros conocemos como algo desechable
para crear nuevas piezas
nuevas piezas de ese material que quizás
nosotros estamos confundiendo que
reciclamos y quizás solo pasa de nuestra
papelera al barril a un basurero y a un
basurero más grande tal y como están
viendo ustedes aquí en esta imagen en un
vertedero en bahía de tela
donde el día de mañana yo puedo
convertir mis tapones en nuevas piezas
hay que conocer bien los materiales que
nosotros consumimos los productos cuáles
son sus propiedades cuáles son sus
características sobre todo porque
tenemos que convertirnos en curadores de
consumo
y tenemos que convertirnos en mejores
humanos humanos que dejan huellas y no
cicatrices
en este proceso
yo fui conociendo cómo fue ese impacto
como diseñador
después de tener pizarras llenas de
post-its que muchos de nosotros hemos
vivido el design thinking y taller tras
taller de design thinking yo quedaba
preguntándome pero bueno cuando viene el
design maker
y entonces fue ahí cuando yo encontré
este nicho y decidí trabajar con un
grupo que para mí ha tenido mucho cariño
toda mi vida y es en esta bahía de tela
y escogí como grupo piloto un grupo
étnico que es muy importante para
nosotros que son los garífunas
los garífunas llevan muchísimos años de
repetir su sistema constructivo es una
arquitectura espontánea que se ha
transmitido de generación en generación
pero lamentablemente como nosotros
tenemos un clima que aparece un episodio
de la serie de los
hay que reconstruirla hay que
reconstruirla y reconstruirla entonces
en este en esta exploración que ha
tenido como diseñador era esa búsqueda
de cómo puede contribuir a esta
arquitectura
es el sistema constructivo que
corresponde a su entorno pero su entorno
es agresivo
en esta exploración el proyecto fue
tomando como una bola de nieve más y más
y más ímpetu fue presentado en madrid en
estoril
en milán
y fue ahí donde yo me fui dando cuenta
que como arquitecto quizás mi
interpretación de estas nuevas piezas
serían texas para impermeabilizar esas
casas de esos garífonas para convertir
mis tapones en esas nuevas piezas
pero en ese transcurso en ese proceso me
di cuenta que no lo sabía todo tampoco
me interesaba saberlo todo es muy
cansado querer saberlo todo
y se trabaja mejor en colectivo en el
2015 se realiza un taller piloto en la
bahía de tela junto con estudiantes de
arquitectura de aquí mismo de la usap y
también integrantes de la comunidad
garífuna
y se lleva a cabo una semana donde a
base de prueba y error se invitaba a que
se equivocarán porque déjenme contarles
que equivocarse es muy bueno porque nos
contribuye como base de datos
y surgieron resultados inesperados
resultados que yo como arquitecto con no
me lo imaginaba y este señor del residuo
de plástico de su casa logró convertir
esto en un timón para su lancha
todo en un proceso muy sencillo
utilizando las mismas herramientas de un
artesano y sus mismas habilidades
utilizando una temperatura que no es
mayor a la que yo necesitaría para
calentar mi panini
con 30 libras de presión 15 minutos y
obtengo uno de estos módulos
un proceso que no tiene desperdicio todo
lo que se va soltando y se va utilizando
se utiliza se reutiliza y los contras
moldes que utilizamos son de esa madera
que teníamos guardada en la bodega que
algún día podría llegar a utilizar
si mantener una agenda de 20 estudiantes
universitarios fue un reto
controlar 80 estudiantes de secundaria
fue una aventura memorable
sobre todo porque una de las grandes
reglas que yo tenía para ellos es que
podían hacer desorden y quisieran pero
claro fue con la condición que tenían
que limpiar después también habían
instrucciones del uso adecuado de las
herramientas que si perdían un dedo pues
que tenían nueve más que no fueran
egoístas
y también surgieron pues resultados
inesperados
con esto se fue haciendo también un
proceso muy dinámico y muy divertido
donde yo invitaba a mis amigos y traían
sus botes de sus casas y los convertimos
en nuevas piezas pero una máquina
trituradora que hacía un ruido tremendo
y les encantaba
y así fue creando este montón de módulos
con composiciones donde yo ya no era más
que arquitecto era un artesano
y hacía composiciones caprichosas y muy
divertidas composiciones que
inevitablemente eran coloridas
para un estilo de vida colorido
the future you
es una evolución del individuo donde
nosotros tenemos que crecer como seres
humanos
y darnos importancia de cuál es nuestro
impacto nuestro perímetro ahí va a ser
medida la evolución del ser humano the
future y you no necesitas saltar más
alto o correr más rápido la evolución
del ser humano debe ser en su
comportamiento
en cómo es nuestro nuestra convivencia
con nuestro entorno
nuestra responsabilidad como
consumidores
de fitur
comienza por nuestros mismos
y sigue por la persona que está a su
lado
[Aplausos]